everyone's excited for the new
Transformers movie bumblebee and this
cast list is on fire now let's check out
10 things you didn't know about the cast
of bumblebee try this Hayley's hit
single the star of the new film
bumblebee is Hailee Steinfeld she plays
Charlie Watson and we love that Hailee
is getting all the screen time she
deserves the young actress is probably
best known for her role as Emily in
pitch perfect 2 and pitch perfect 3 so
it's no huge secret that Haley can sing
she's got an amazing voice in 2016 she
released a hit single called starving
this was a collaboration with some other
artists she sang with grey which is an
American electric pop duo consisting of
two brothers this song was produced by
the Russian German producer DJ Zedd and
it was a hit it actually hit the number
one spot in Mexico and it was number 12
on the US Hot 100 billboard she's
released a few other singles but that is
by far her most successful one she was
even an opening act for one of Meghan
Trainor's tours we wonder if she'll get
a chance to sing in bumblebee have you
listened to any of her music let us know
in the comments the talented Thoreau's
justin theroux is a familiar face in
hollywood you've probably seen him in
lots of stuff before he was with
Jennifer Aniston for a while recently
you might have seen him in the spy who
dumped me or Star Wars the last Jedi and
bumblebee justin is playing the
transformer dropkick but Justin isn't
the only talented famous member of his
family two of his uncle's our
best-selling award-winning novelists
named Paul Theroux and Alexander Thoreau
their novels have been turned into
several movies justin has two famous
cousins
Marcel Poirot is a best-selling author
like his dad
Justin's other cousin might be the most
famous Thoreau Lewis Thoreau is a
journalist and a documentary filmmaker
and he is well known for his in-depth
investigative reporting Justin's mom
Phyllis Thoreau is also a journalist
she's been working for The Washington
Post for a long time
Justin's brother Sebastian is a
production assistant in Hollywood and
his
worked on several hit shows that the
road family sure has some talent in
their genes
[Music]
okay it's always a big deal with a new
actor plays an old character so who is
voicing bumblebee anyway the role
belongs to Dylan O'Brien Dylan didn't
get a start in Hollywood until 2011 he
was in a movie called high road it was
an indie film and the whole thing was
improvised we can't imagine making a
movie without a script he's been in
several films since then but you
probably know him best from TV Dylan
plays Stiles stilinski in Teen Wolf
from 2011 until 2017 but how did Dylan
really get discovered
well like so many modern celebrities he
was a YouTube star he made a whole bunch
of short films he wrote them directed
them and starred in them when he was a
senior in high school his YouTube
channel copy I of a director she cast
him in a web series that she was
directing after that he enrolled in
acting classes at the local community
college but he got the role on Teen Wolf
just a few months later and now he's
voicing one of the most well-known robot
characters of all time
bumblebee what have you done
highly educated actress Angela Bassett
might be one of the most successful
actresses of all time
she is won over 30 Awards in her career
she regularly plays amazing historic
characters like Tina Turner dr. Betty
Shabazz and Rosa Parks she has been
nominated for an Academy Award four
times and in this new movie Angela
Bassett is voicing shatter angela is
extremely talented in her acting career
but she is also very highly educated she
has two degrees one is a bachelor's in
african-american studies that she earned
in 1980 the other is a master's in fine
arts
but these degrees aren't just from any
old college Angela Bassett went to Yale
University that's one of the top schools
in the world and one of the hardest to
get into it's even more impressive that
she got in in the 1970s as a black
American woman universities like that
didn't have a ton of diversity back then
but angela is just that incredible she
obviously learned a lot of great stuff
there and her first degree explains why
she loves playing historical roles of
important black women after she
graduated with her master's she really
kicked off her acting career stay in
school kids everyone's favorite donkey
Peter Cullen is returning as the voice
of Optimus Prime and Bumblebee he has
been voicing the most famous transformer
since the original cartoon in the 1980s
and Optimus Prime is his favorite role
ever Peter Cullen has been doing voice
acting since the 1960s not only has he
worked on lots of commercials and small
roles but he has also acted in some very
famous movies and TV shows he voiced a
grundle in the original My Little Pony
movie from the 80s he's played Optimus
Prime more than any other role but his
second most famous role is something
completely different Peter Cullen is the
voice of your he first began voicing
everyone's favorite sad donkey on a
cartoon TV show in 1988 he has since
played ER more than two dozen times the
last time he played the donkey was on an
episode of doc mcstuffins in 2017 it's
crazy that the most powerful Autobot in
the universe is also the world's saddest
donkey listen closely to his voice in
bumblebee to see if you can hear any
similarities bilingual wrestler John
Cena is one talented guy he of course
got a start as a professional wrestler
and he is one of the most famous faces
in the WWE a few years ago John also
proved that he is a great actor he
became respected for his acting skills
after he starred in the 2006 film the
Marine since then he has starred in
several comedy and action flicks
he even voiced the main character in
ferdinand recently and he does all of
this while staying an active wrestler
but john has another hidden talent he
speaks Mandarin Chinese and he is mostly
self-taught he uses a tutor and
flashcards considering John is part
Italian and part french-canadian
Mandarin seems like an odd choice but a
few years ago he tried to break into the
Chinese world of wrestling he learned a
few key phrases in the most common
Chinese language and he fell in love
with it he then went on to learn a lot
more Mandarin and he has shown off his
Chinese skills in several interviews we
think this is a really cool skill to
have
do you speak more than one language let
us know in the comments theater
philanthropist John Ortiz is playing
agent Powell in bumblebee John has been
in Hollywood for a long time he usually
plays serious roles in dramas and action
flicks most recently he played a
detective in the Jennifer Garner
thriller peppermint but John Ortiz does
a lot more than just act he helps
support other actors with his foundation
back in 1992 a Broadway play debuted
called death in the maiden the entire
storyline was about Latino people in
South America but there was not a single
Latino after in the cast this was a huge
controversy and it brought to light the
struggles of being a minority actor john
founded Latino actors base to help
Latino actors and bring awareness to the
racial issue in Cass
later on the group expanded to help more
than just actors with Latino heritage he
began to work with Philip Seymour
Hoffman another famous actor and they
changed the name to labyrinth theater
company the lab part of the name still
honors its roots as a Latino
organization while helping other actors
this is a great cause we think it's
pretty cool that John is so passionate
about helping other actors Dylan's major
injury the voice of bumble bee has only
been in the Hollywood scene for a few
years but he became super famous after
he played Thomas in The Maze Runner
movies these were based on a series of
young adult novels about a dystopian
future Society and they were so good the
movies were a huge success Dylan O'Brien
made it through the first two movies
without any major incidents but he was
seriously injured during the filming of
the third movie he was doing a stunt
where he was strapped into a harness on
a moving vehicle something happened and
he was jerked off the first car and
slammed into another vehicle
ouch he was rushed to the hospital he
had a concussion facial fractures and
various lacerations and it turned out to
be a more serious of an injury than they
thought it was he was in the hospital
for a few days then his recovery took
awhile this was back in 2016 it pushed
production back several months the rest
of the cast and crew were sent home
because Dylan had a long road ahead but
he got better and Maze Runner the death
cure came out in 2018 we are so glad
that he is okay Academy Award winner we
all know Hailee Steinfeld from the pitch
perfect movies she stole our hearts as
the sassy new member after some of the
Barton Bellas graduated Haley has been
acting since she was 10 years old she
had a few very small roles at first but
her big break came in the movie true
grit
she played Mattie Ross a teen girl who
recruits a US Marshal to help her find
the man who ended her father's life it
was a hit drama and she starred opposite
Hollywood legends like Jeff Bridges and
Matt Damon we cannot wait to see what
other great roles she plays in the
future and we are excited to see her
star and Bumblebee are you a Hailee
Steinfeld fan show us how much you love
her in the comments section wrestler
actor rapper there's no doubt about it
John Sena is one cool dude he's a
legendary wrestler
is a really great actor and now we know
he can speak Chinese but did you know he
also raps
he used to at least John Sena used to
write his own rap music and back in 2005
he actually released a whole rap album
he teamed up with another rapper who
went by the name thoug trademark the
trademark is actually John's cousin the
album was called you can't see me and it
had 17 tracks it was really pretty
popular it was produced by both WWE
Music Group and Columbia Records which
helps make it successful it hit number
15 on the Billboard 200 charts and then
it went on to become a platinum album
after selling over a million copies you
don't see me hit platinum status in 2010
have you ever heard John Senna's music
let us know what you think seriously we
are starting to wonder if there is
anything Johnson I can't do he is so
talented and he is so much more than
just a WWE star are you pumped about the
new bumblebee movie sound off in the
comments and that's a wrap on the 10
things you didn't know about the cast of
bumblebee be sure to check out our
community page for more great content
and don't forget to subscribe
[Music]